Last week, you advised that I pulse the fed mendazole in my
JTP, so that's the Joe Tippen's protocol, due to the out of range labs of creatine and
estimated glomerular filtration rate
on my lab. So I paused it for a week now. Subsequently, I've learned that the dosages that I was on
was much higher than normal, and maybe it's advisable for me to cut the dosages in half,
and maybe my I've erected dose is also an issue. I've been taking 225 milligrams of fed mendazole
twice a day, and 32 milligrams of Ivermectin twice a day on five days off two days. I think they
are higher than what I was seeing in other places. These are closer to turbo cancer doses
that some people give. I was also curious why you looked at fed mendazole as a culprit to pause
rather than the Ivermectin since the fed mendazole, 225 milligrams doses for a 10-pound dog, and I'm
155 pounds around 75 kilograms. Okay, so let's go back to dosages of fed mendazole, and
or Ivermectin for somebody with cancer. So the typical Joe Tippen's protocol for fed mendazole
is 225 milligrams once a day, three days on, four days off, and continue it on that cycle. Now there's
people that have much more aggressive cancer, and they're doing 440 milligrams per day of fed mendazole
three days on, four days off, and there's people that are taking it even more aggressive approach,
and they're doing 444 milligrams twice a day every day of the week, and there's people that are
taking it even more aggressive approach, and they're up to 888. So they're taking four packets of
fed mendazole every day, every day of the week. So it depends on where the person is at. So again,
I would agree if your cancer isn't being aggressive right now, if you feel great and you don't feel like
you're in a more crisis state, then you should probably drop back to the standard protocol of fed mendazole,
which is just one packet, which is 222 milligrams of fed mendazole once per day.
And then a person, again, would titrate up on that dosage based upon how their aggressiveness or
their cancer, how aggressive they want to be with it, and keep in mind that you're running
kidney and liver function tests on a very regular basis to make sure that you're not having issues
with detoxification pathways and elevated AST, ALT, alkaline phosphates, creatinine, and EGFR,
like you had. So you're looking at kidney function tests, you're looking at liver function tests.
So why was I saying that fed mendazole has a greater chance of being the culprit of affecting
your kidney function test and liver function test? It's just my historical data that I have
seen patients over a period of time and seen, you know, what's the greater chance of
having an effect as a fed mendazole, a negative effect to liver markers and
kidney markers as a fed mendazole or hyperbacter that it's a fed mendazole.
So, and again, so what could be raising your kidney markers could be the fed mendazole,
could be the hyperbacter, could be that of those, could be either one of those, right? Could be
something else. So how would you know that? Well, you could just pulse off one and see if those
numbers go back into normal and go back on the other, but you were just making that guess.
As far as the dose of Ivermectin, the standard dose of Ivermectin that has been used out there,
okay, so let's go from the simplest, the simplest dose of Ivermectin that was used to help prevent
you know, like COVID or something like that was typically just three milligrams of Ivermectin,
not based upon weight, three milligrams Ivermectin per day. If you had COVID or were thought
you were exposed to COVID or or you were, you know, in the middle of COVID, people were taking
12 milligrams Ivermectin per day, not based on weight, but with cancer, it's based upon weight,
it's based upon your kilogram weight. So you got to just pull out your handy calculator on your
computer. How do I convert my weight in pounds to kilograms? This person converted their weight
to kilograms. They weigh about 75 kilograms. So the standard beginning dose of Ivermectin for cancer
is half a milligram per kilogram weight. So if you weigh 75 kilograms, what's half of 75? 37.5. So you
start off by taking 37.5 milligrams Ivermectin per day. 37.5 per day would be the myelus dose.
And then you tight trade up. So depending again on if you're really ill and you really need to fight
this, you got stage 4 cancer, you need to be really active fighting this, you get you start at that
37.5. And then after you're able to tolerate that, several weeks go by, you move up to
1 milligram per kilogram dose, which if you weigh 75 kilograms, you now be taking 75 milligrams per
day, 75 milligrams per day. And then you can move up to 1.5 milligrams per kilogram weight,
and up to two milligrams per kilogram weight. So the maximum dose of somebody at 75 kilograms
would be 150 milligrams, or excuse me, 150 milligrams of Ivermectin per day. Hope that helps. So it's
really not confusing what you just sit down and do the math with it.